hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie and today we're gonna do a
hero section I I think this will be
probably easier than the the side nav
for sure mainly because we don't need to
import anything from the content
management system so we just need to
bring in what we've done on the the demo
site so let me show you in case you
haven't seen that so we're gonna bring
this section in and just a little you
know little parallax effect not really a
big deal I don't think the text that's
that's here or the link here is gonna
change very often so this is fine if we
just hard code this and also the image
for now I'm just gonna hard code I'm not
sure how often will want this to change
but for now I don't know maybe I'll use
the same stock stock image or or a
random image figure that out when we get
there so the only thing that I've really
worked on since the last time was
putting this logo in it needs some
prices some padding at the top on the
bottom I just got this in just a few
minutes ago so I haven't really worked
on it but yeah it's not not bad a little
bit different than the original because
we we got a new web logo but it's not
bad
hey everybody get some people in the
live chat now let's see okay a head
heavy on says I want to learn C++
[Music]
yeah I am I don't know much C++ so we're
gonna work with it a little bit but not
really not really an expert but we do
have someone that's frequently on the
live chat that's putting together some
tutorial videos for C++ so I don't know
if I'm Berto is it's in the live chat
today or it's watching but Umberto if if
you're watching maybe you could give
some info about your YouTube stuff and I
can't remember if you had some stuff up
already or if you're still working on it
but anyway let us know if you're here
otherwise when Alberto is ready
I'll definitely throw a link to his his
videos up here so because I'd like to
watch them too and so I could figure out
a little bit more what's going on with
this Aramis site we're working on
c-sharp that's what I have my mistake
eze e on said C++ we're working c-sharp
so in Umberto's working on c-sharp so my
apologies for that the camera froze
already Wow we had so much luck with it
on Friday it didn't freeze at all so I
don't know I haven't done anything
different it just freezes some days and
other days it doesn't I said before I
was going to try to work on using my
camera as a as a webcam like our upside
my phone camera as a webcam and I looked
it up but there's not it would be a lot
easier if I had Linux but on on a Mac it
was a little difficult like there's an
easy way to do it with some programs on
Windows and there's a really easy way to
do it on Linux but on a Mac it's not so
easy so some stuck with this the
built-in camera that freezes alright
let's get started
hey Kevin's in the live chat I haven't
seen Kevin in a while how's it going
alright so I think the first thing we'll
need to do is work on this container so
if you see we have a container div and
so we actually have several content
container divs going on here so it's a
little bit a little bit complex I think
there there are more divs than necessary
on this page so we'll see if we can cut
them down that that might be good just
simplify things but this first div you
can see it wraps everything and then it
has margins on the side because it has a
max width of 1280 pixels and then it's
setting you know margin:0 auto so it's
centered so what we want to do is I
think what the best thing will be is if
we just completely remove whatever
styles are on that and then we just use
the layout from materialise going
forward I think my original intention
was just to do a minimal amount to the
home page and try not to affect a lot of
the other components going on but now I
think I think we're just gonna have to
change a lot of stuff I don't know that
it'll work it'll be get really
complicated to try to have a lot of a
lot of different things going on try to
cancel it all out so my plan right now
is to just get rid of a lot of what was
already going on on this site so a lot
of this stuff and the styles that went
along with this and then just rethink
okay what do we really need on this page
and you know where are we gonna put it
and then build it out with materialized
and that's if you're not familiar with
that it's it's like bootstrap it's a CSS
framework except it's material design
and yeah I mean I think that would be
that would be better right I mean if
we're gonna if we're gonna redo this
like let's let's redo it and as far as
the interior pages go there are quite a
few interior pages but they all follow
like a certain pattern so you know for
each academic department they all have
their own page but they're all the same
template and a lot of templates get
reused for multiple things so I think it
won't be quite as hard as I thought I
remember last week I was talking about
trying to just make our CSS selectors
very specific so we won't mess other
things up but but I don't know III think
it would be better if we don't worry
about that and go through I really think
we got a shot at redesigning you know a
good bit of this and if they're conflict
if things look weird then free wife
Gantt refers again Wow and it was like
in the same position that my face was in
the same spot so anyway enough talking
about it but that's kind of my thought
on it this this week I'm thinking a
little differently I don't know maybe
after we dig into it a I'll change my
mind again but for right now I guess I'm
feeling ambitious about this this
project okay so first things first let's
find that container div and and you by
the way you can check this out as I'm
updating it it's franciscan dot edu
slash home test all all together home
test the code as of right now is not
publicly available on github hopefully I
can get it publicly available at some
point okay so it's not here it's not
here it's in the main
I really wish the file structure was a
bit more organized here I didn't really
have a choice about that this was all
made before I even started working here
master faders there it is see this is to
the play that's frustrating so we have a
master pages folder within the site
folder that has main mastered CS and
main master but that's not really the
one that you edit to get anything done
there's a master pages folder that's a
sibling folder of the site folder that
has the same files in it and those are
the ones that really do something when
you edit them so but there are other
files in the site folder that seemingly
do stuff when you edit them so it's I
don't and I have not figured out the
logic of this yet completely but I think
what we want is here and we want to
format this as HTML it's amazing how
much you rely on you know just something
simple like the you know the different
colors in in the code editor trying to
go I know if I try to go and have to
edit something where I don't have the
highlighting it's it's difficult you
know not impossible but you know your
eyes just get used to certain way that
things are and it's hard to to pick
things out of the code without it okay
yeah I think this is what we want and we
should have the main there we go
this is the div that I think we want to
turn into our main div in terms of
materialized so let's make sure okay so
we have body form which we need the form
okay so the first div after that great
so this is header its ends up being our
header div and then this will be main so
that's that's awesome that's what you
want so what I'm gonna do and we'll see
how much this messes things up but I'm
gonna change it let me find out where
that closing div tag is first body form
it should be this one let's double check
I'm hoping it'll highlight up here
it did not maybe it's not that one do
they have the footer as okay I think
they have the footer as with being
within the main I'll have to double
check but I think in materialise you put
the footer outside of the main div so
we're not to the footer yet that'll
probably be the next video that we do
assuming we get the hero section done
today or if I finish it in the morning
tomorrow but I think that this is
probably our div that we're looking for
so let's change this to main and I went
too far and then let's take all this out
and change it to main if it's just CSS
that was happening with those tags then
we should be fine if there was some
JavaScript that was trying to reference
those classes then we may get some
errors but it's worth a shot
see if we could get it to work so let's
refresh see what we have I have dev
tools open on the other screen and there
there are no errors in the console and
look at that so this was actually best
case scenario in my mind so
automatically the styles that were make
making that a
find max width of 1280 pixels are gone
and we can see now let me find my main
here okay so the main is taking up the
full page which is awesome
it does have we will have to adjust it a
bit you can see it's kind of going up
under the that the header so I'm not
worried about right now we have no
content but I imagine if we get some
content in there might be cut off it's
only slightly being cut off so that may
be all right
but that's a good first step so now we
have main in there now we can start to
put some things in here and they should
be full width and that's what we need
for that hero section initially when
before I got here when there was the
company that was hired for the site was
building it it was requested that the
site be a full width site and from what
I understand the people that work at my
University were told that that would be
much too difficult to do which is insane
to me because I mean literally it's one
line of CSS to change that max width now
would it throw off some other stuff you
have to judge probably but to say it was
too hard was I don't know I mean maybe
like best-case scenario the person just
was unaware of what to do I would hate
to think that they were purposely
misleading him but I guess that happens
sometimes all right so let's find out
now what that section is what goes in
here so I guess we look for this content
yeah I'm not sure that I really want to
get into making more of these I don't
I'm gonna call them components I'm not
really sure what they'd be called in you
know dotnet but I don't know that I want
to make more of these components I think
I may rather just try to work with
what's already there we'll see how it
goes if it's too complicated then maybe
it might be better to just clean up this
structure and and make our own and you
know configure our files you know like
we would do maybe four for some of our
other projects where we'd have a
components folder and you know a folder
for all our CSS or images I mean maybe
we could I think at least at some point
this may have been organized like that
and then it just got really messy but
for right now let's see if we can find
let's see if we can find where this is
pulling some things from now I already
found let's see that keV I think froze
again
I'm gonna move my my OBS window to the
to the middle screen so I'll notice
faster whether or not my screens frozen
actually having the background this
little I don't know if you can see that
but I have a little USB like plasma ball
going back there so I thought that would
be fun it's fun for you all to see this
oh and I forgot to set my timer so let's
do that
so we already started so I'm just gonna
assume that we've taken I don't know
what time is it probably 10 minutes
something we've taken in 10 so we'll see
I'll set it but I'll keep an eye on that
and if if we get down to it and it's
like 10 minutes left then I think we'll
be safe to stop and do five minutes of
question-and-answer I do want to try to
be done by 2:30 Eastern Time so just
about an hour of a stream I have a
meeting at 3:00 actually I should
double-check because when I said that it
just occurred to me that maybe my
meetings at 3:30 instead of three and if
that's the case I could go a little bit
longer let's see no it is it three hours
right
okay so I have a meeting at 3:00 so I
wish I could stream for longer today but
oh well I mean I pick something that I
thought we could get done the hero
section in a short amount of time so
we'll try it yes let me find out I think
the home page wireframe which I already
have a test version of that
I had a test version what happened to it
maybe it's in I'm wondering if there we
go
that makes sense okay so I was looking
in this site section but as I said
earlier I think that this site section
here is just a copy I'm pretty sure that
this does nothing when you edit it and
at some point someone just copied it and
I don't know why you name that folder
site instead of backup or something like
that but this is what we want so we have
this test home wireframe I think this is
what we need I think I already linked
this up okay so main test master
okay
content place already and what was that
main so caught it was content
placeholder main
I'm trying to find the name
maybe it's in
oh okay now I see I kept wondering how I
did this so I actually did this months
ago I made these tests wireframes and
but I it was throwing me off because as
you can see you know there's a lot in
here but there's not a lot on the on the
actual page right there's there's
nothing in that you know main section
here right
and even when I looked in my inspected
it and dev tools there's really not much
there at all
but this is how I must have done it and
I really don't remember but no one else
has access to these files that would
even attempt to do anything so it must
have been me I came in here in each
section you can set it to be visible or
not so there's I think four I think
there's like four main sections to the
page so these three sections and then
above it there's a like a top section
and so I just set everything to
visibility false so that's that's cool
we can selectively start putting things
back in and now I know at least what to
do so we already have this hero section
here so I'm just going to keep this I'm
gonna remove everything that's in there
right now but I'm gonna keep the name
because that certainly fits what we're
trying to do and I'm just going to click
set this to true if I could spell it to
this I'm gonna set it to true now
hopefully we can see something after I
refresh I guess not
let's I'm gonna double check and just
inspect
Oh actually yeah we do have something
great
all right so you can't really tell but
there is now we do have a hero section
just kind of just the bare bones of it
in you see an in-depth tool so you can
see it says hero outer wrapper right so
we have this this section with a class
of hero hey I don't think that was in
there before oh actually now it looks
like we even though I set the visibility
to false we still have these outer kind
of these outer divs there's just no
content being filled in them huh
all right well let's let's see let's put
some stuff in there and see what what
happens okay
so let's find out our hero section
okay so this is what we need to keep
that and then okay here's our section
okay I think we need to keep I think we
need to keep this alert so I'm pretty
sure there's some type of there's some
type of alert that would happen if there
was an emergency on campus that should
pop up I've never actually seen it
happen but I think that's what this is
so whatever we do in this section we
need to incorporate this somehow and
maybe we'll try to test it and see if we
can get it to pop up because I don't
want to mess that up in case there was
some type of emergency but everything
else we should be able to get rid of
so we'll keep well let's let's grab our
code first before I figure out what to
keep and what not to keep all right so
let me grab yeah this whole thing here
it's gonna bethe and that's gonna be
it's gonna take the place of our section
so I'm not gonna have these section
elements what I'll have is a div with a
class of section that's how that's how I
have everything set up already in the
CSS from the other site so I want to
keep it like that as I said last week
these tabs are killing me but I'm just
gonna that relax
it's amazing how like something little
like that just bothers you okay so now
let's get rid of yeah let's get rid of
this
let's get rid of that part in this part
we do need to be we need to be careful
about some of this because I think we do
want to it's alright I'll take it out
because we always have a copy of this
that we can refer to basically what I
was worried about is at some point
within this featured section there is I
think there was something that pulled in
data about his future stories slider
yeah it was this feature story slider
okay I think we're fine to take kind of
this stuff out right now
and that we can always just look and put
something else in if we need to later on
yeah let's take this out for now and you
don't need this anymore
you no need this anymore either now we
will put
yes we want this alert still I guess
we'll put this in within our our section
here since that's how it was before
okay all right let's say that see what
it looks like and after I see what's
going on here
I'm not bad not bad we got some stuff on
the page now I think yeah I thought the
image should load because it's just a
CSS background all right not bad that
was way easier than I thought
so since we had a lot of the CSS
pre-built this just works right we had
it in here so I kind of feel like my
title actually have some weird stuff
going on so let's check out the CSS I
feel like my titles misleading because I
said you know we're doing a pair of like
parallax hero section but I didn't
actually demonstrate at all how to do it
you got to be kidding me I'm I'm frozen
again I'm have to watch this video at
some point and just see like was I only
could you only see the live video for a
few minutes for this whole thing I'm
gonna check my timer and then okay about
three minutes all right when I gets down
to ten minutes we'll do our five minutes
of question and answer and then sorry I
haven't been looking at the live chat I
actually I covered it up with dev tools
for most of the time so if you asked the
question I will get to it I'm not
intentionally ignoring the live chat I
just I inadvertently covered it with
with dev tools okay so what I'd like to
do then since we have it here we have it
working what I want to do is figure out
why this isn't centered center it figure
out why we're not getting the the color
on this it should we should have it hmm
I'll see I actually I think I know why
the colors not working on this but we'll
get the right color here because I don't
want that color we'll get this centered
and then in the process of doing that
we'll take a look at the CSS you already
saw the the mark up the HTML extremely
simple but the CSS is where we have all
this other stuff happening so we'll take
a look at that and that'll probably be
that'll probably be everything that we
get to so I doubt that that will take
the full 25 minutes of our next Pomodoro
session so we can we'll just get that
done once we're done with that then
we'll do question and answer for the
rest and hopefully finish up around in
about about a half an hour I just I
looked at a lot of chat kevin says yeah
most of the time we're frozen that's
crazy I don't know if you remember so a
couple days last week got freeze on and
off Friday what the entire time I think
it was nearly two hours didn't freeze at
all and now today I don't think I can go
two minutes without freezing that's just
crazy I have all the same programs
running I've changed nothing if anything
I've actually closed some windows I had
a lot more chrome windows and tabs open
on Friday so oh well like I said I want
to try to find a real webcam at some
point and hopefully just be done with
this this problem I probably just took
up the rest of the few minutes yeah it's
close enough
let's do five minutes of
question-and-answer and then we'll
finish up okay I'm scrolling way up to
the top now and try to get through as
much as I can
hey everyone a lot of people saying hi
everyone thanks for watching frozen
again that's
okay cool Kevin I just saw you said
haven't done parallax before so I wanted
to see how that works yeah I'm gonna
show you just a super simple way to do
it there are you can do some really cool
things a different way and I'll explain
the other way I'm not going to show it
right now but basically I've seen the
ways to do parallax fall for me in my
mind at least in the two main categories
and one is just plain CSS and the other
one is using javascript to track scroll
and positions today I'm going to show
you how I did this with just CSS and
then I'll explain a little bit of how
you might want to do it in JavaScript if
you do want to see a better way to do it
check out dev tips it's a YouTube
channel so dev tips has a video I don't
remember the name of it but it talks
about doing parallax effects and I think
if I it's been a long time since I've
seen this video but I remember there was
some really cool stuff that was
happening in that video that he was
doing some some parallax at like
different speeds and things and having
like three different images all appear
to be going at different speeds over top
of each other it was just really cool so
he's actually the guy that does that
channel doesn't do a lot of videos
anymore cuz he got a job at Google and
and then now he's just really busy with
that but he did have a lot of good
videos before so I recommend that to
learn to some kind of it more advanced
techniques but today out I'll show you
something really easy
there are so many messages saying that I
my camera's first thing yeah I just saw
Kevin said legacy code yes yes
definitely this is the this whole
project is just going to be trying to
figure out what's going on here and make
the best of it
okay no beer says Jessie search input
looks much better but when it focus it
and I'm looking okay I see the rest of
it it comes up with height or border
maybe that doesn't look very nice are
you talking about this search input or
this search input which I should
probably look at it on the on this site
so this one we're still getting that
this thing where I need to fix this it
should not automatically go to the
search page or maybe this one yeah this
one's doing there's some stuff that's
happening here that should not happen
that I fixed on the the demo page so it
seems like there's there's some things
that I tried to override that aren't
being overridden now and I'm not sure
why so off to check that out
all right Brian has any questions says
I'm probably unleashing a beast but
what's everybody using is a build tool
these days I'm still using gulp because
I'm finding webpack overly complicated
for my taste all right I actually for
simple projects so for you for this
project which is just like static like
regular HTML you know CSS JavaScript I'm
actually using gulp for this so you
I mean if anyone wants to check out how
I'm using it this is it's on github not
on my github account this is on the the
fus mark on one the same one that our
last couple of projects have have been
on but I have this starter template code
there with gulps ooh but I find for
small projects like that really simple
ones gulp is extremely easy to use and I
do find webpack to be more complicated
and overkill I'm sure that's just
because I haven't taken the time to
really study webpack maybe if I had I
would I would use webpack more but what
I'm working with react I I'm a certainly
use webpack but almost always I
bootstrap the project somehow with
either create react app or next and they
take care of the webpack config for me
so I mean it's there's one less thing
that I don't have to learn right now and
helps me get started faster definitely
want to learn it you know better at some
point just haven't really taken the time
to do that yet
okay all right cool I did get to the
bottom of the live chat the timer just
went up a few seconds ago so we'll go
back to this I didn't see Samson says I
like your videos Thank You Samson
I appreciate that thanks for watching
all right so let's start this Pomodoro
timer I think will definitely be done
before this goes up but let's let's just
see what's going on here
first things first and this hopefully
will be an easy fix
I know that's hard to see maybe we
should just change the color on that
while we're in here let's see what's
going on
let me bring let's move this over and
bring dev tools over here I'm not sure
where I had this dev tools from I'll
just get rid of that let's see why this
should be see this Center here should be
going down it should be inherited and
everything within it should be centered
but it does not look like that's
happening
I just want to I want to try to find it
and see what's overriding it okay so it
it it is trying to be applied but it's
something is overriding it so what is
that let's find it
let's go to our whoops it's not what I
wanted let's go over here and look at
our text align so it's being aligned
left and there we go
interesting oh I see this is this is
really interesting so it I don't know if
you can see that but it's form and then
P so since this is more specific than
just the center class
this is overriding it but this is on it
thinks it's in a form because of course
this entire thing is in a form so what
we'll want to do then is we're probably
going to run into more issues because
this is within a form so we may want to
use a custom version of materialized but
for now I'm not gonna get into that I
think what I'll do is just
yeah in this case I'm just gonna add on
to our custom CSS file to handle this
and we'll see we'll see how much more
maybe I'll have to check out the non
minified materialized CSS just to see
how many things are formed specific so
for now we can just find let's find our
CSS there we go new design and let's go
to
alright let's just put this at the top
here so I'm gonna say Center
Center
and I'm used to Adam like just
automatically giving me good suggestions
I'll need to get a similar package for
Visual Studio code been spoiled by that
okay so let's see if that worked it
should be specific enough now oops
I guess not
are we still still happening
let's add one more let's add this now
this should do it there we go okay all
right so that that work so basically we
just got more specific with our
selectors and now we have this in the
center let's yeah let's add in some
materialized as a class
it has these classes for text color and
things so unless this is mm I guess it's
being
something is overriding this right now
okay
yeah
so the styles.css for the you know that
was here for the original site is
overriding this right now so we're gonna
have to put that white text class on
both of these normally you don't have to
you can just put it on a container and
it'll work
but let's put this on here
and put it here that should do what we
needed to do
okay I just looked at the live chat here
and Kevin says use important and this is
not pretty but it can be helpful when
dealing with legacy code yeah definitely
it definitely can whoa that's crazy it
still did not override that now I really
want to know what's going on here let's
see it could be that I spelled something
wrong let's check that first
yep I forgot the equals
I see that thanks Jambi I'd I just
noticed that you already got that I said
the good thing I should remember that
more often if something happens on a
website and my thought is how is that
even possible I should look for a
mistake that I made because computers
don't just do things differently right
that they just respond to what you give
them so if they're doing something weird
then that means I probably gave it
something weird
all right cool so at least we can see
this text and the last thing that I want
to do before I show you this CSS for how
we did this parallax is just check on
this button now I was surprised at first
that we had this color but I think what
I had done on the demo site is I was
using a modified version of materialized
there's I took their CSS file and I went
and I changed their sass variables
because I think I I think what I did was
I imported all their sad stuff and then
just ran it through gulp and had it up
just all bundled together you know with
the custom stuff that I was doing and so
that's why we're back to this default
stuff because I brought in materialized
CSS from the CDN for this project so
what we could do I mean really we just
need to change this background color and
yeah let's just grab this for now let's
just grab this whole thing for now I'm
gonna paste it did at some point I do
want to add in my own variables into the
SAS for materialized and then I'll run
that through basically what I'm gonna do
is just pare down all the CSS to what I
just need for this site and take out
everything I don't need then then I'll
convert that so I'm gonna do that with
the SAS I'll convert it just to plain
CSS then I'll bring it in and use it for
this project but I'm not gonna do that
until we're almost finished otherwise
I'm not gonna know what I need and what
I don't need so until then I'll just
have to put in a few things here and
there to make it look right and then I
can you know remove those places where I
override things so this is going to be
one of those places and
let's see
let's try to comment out the stuff that
I think I can get rid of later on so I'm
just keeping I just want to change the
background color that's why I got rid of
all that stuff all that stuff obviously
will still be applied we just want to
override this and I can grab that color
from actually now that I'm looking at
this I don't see all here it is
there's the sass I was missing it so
we'll get components here and go into
variables of course it's it's an
alphabetical order I should have known
okay the variables are green FES yellow
okay now I need to go to color so you
can see where the variables are coming
in here for our secondary color I made
it that yellow but I'm importing that
from colors or color dot s CSS so you
can see I've made these custom colors
here so anyway this is all I want right
now just the hex code but this is what
we're going to do at you know later on
towards the end of the project
okay
all right and that should do it give it
a refresh all right cool so I'm not sure
if all haha the hover we didn't bring
over the Hubbard all right let's do that
oops I forgot to click it there we go
all right so
so let's add
the same thing for the hover actually
let's be a little bit smarter about that
probably if I wanted to really make this
better I would have a slightly different
hover color but for right now I don't
really care that's going to be handled
automatically if we put in the correct
variables into the SAS file it'll like
automatically lighten or darken things
so I'm not worried about it now
okay all right oops
I still have Ron no I don't doesn't
really look like he's doing very much
hovering now okay I can see a slight
change yeah the the change of color
would be good but I'm not gonna worry
about that now okay cool so we have this
this parallax thing going on let's check
out how we did it so we're in the
section with the class of here oh yeah
with the ID of hero so here's what we
did so our container div for that
section and let's so here we have this
is the entire section here so you have a
container div with the ID of hero and
then inside it we have another div and
that's what holds the text and the
button so right now we're just going to
worry about this container div so on
that div I've given it a minimum height
of 80 V H okay so that's 80% of the
height of the screen so that's V H is
viewport height I wanted it to just be
80 because I want I you can do a here a
section that covers the screen
completely and I do like that sometimes
but my boss would like it if some of the
content down below were immediately
visible because the site right now has
these these little news stories and
things immediately visible so he didn't
want to lose that so I really wanted to
have a clean kind of hero section and
said well why don't we do it like this
we won't have it be full height but
we'll leave space here for those other
things to still be visible so we'll get
to that and build that section out at
some point but for now let's that's why
I didn't make it fullscreen
alright and here's the the parallax part
of it so we've taken this image and
right now this is just a stock photo and
we've set it as the background image
then we've set the background attachment
to fixed that's what that's what the
parallax is we've also put background
size cover so it covers you know
everything up and then I've also done a
few things here so I've changed the
image dimensions based on our media
queries so that on a smaller screen it
would load a smaller image and also
different dimensions so even on a
smaller screen you can see these are all
landscape this one actually changes to
portrait because at this point you'd
probably be on a phone in portrait mode
so I like to do that it just it looks a
lot nicer on a phone in your portrait
mode one thing that note one thing to
remember when you're using this is this
does not work on iOS so usually what I
end up doing is I I do something just
for iOS so I don't think I did it now I
don't see any special stuff but for that
but I'll have like a special class I'll
check for if it's iOS and then put some
sort of class on to change this and then
basically I can either I can either use
a JavaScript parallax effect at that
point or if I don't care about the
parallax as much I can just have the
image in there it's just a normal image
that has no no effect so I I haven't
tried it with any of the newer versions
of iOS it's probably been a like a year
since I've tested it so maybe it's
different now but it was like that you
know a year ago
and and that's it that's all you need to
get that that parallax that parallax
effect now if you did want to do this
with jQuery or JavaScript or you know
whatever I mean a lot of people do this
with jQuery cuz jQuery is like just very
easy to do things like this with I just
I wonder how I would do this with react
that would be cool we'll have to do that
one day on a react project but the
benefit of doing it with JavaScript is
that you can do you can do different
things you can have a different speed of
the parallax effect you could have
different effects of like you have
things coming in from the side and
moving so you could do a lot of crazy
things I don't really like a lot of that
stuff going on it's distracting
sometimes but it can be cool if done
well but it would work you know on on
any device that has JavaScript enabled
so you're gonna be able to have it work
you know on on an iPhone you know
running Safari so you have more control
but I mean it's just it just kind of
depends on what you need right this is
by far the easiest way to do it and for
me it's it's worked for most for most
cases yeah so again we get that effect
and it just seems as if this is staying
still in the background this image and
everything else is just flowing over top
of it
all right so I think that's it I want to
see how fast we did that okay not bad we
took up a lot of the time and so we're
almost right about the time when I
wanted to be finished so I'm gonna go
through and answer some more questions I
know this was kind of a shorter shorter
video if you can't stick around for the
question/answer that's awesome
you know just thank you for being here
and and watching if you can stick around
that's great too please put your
questions in now and if you can help
answer questions I would appreciate that
so let me scroll up to where I left off
okay cool so not not too much so we
should get through this in a few minutes
abdul-aziz says says good evening hey
how's it going thanks for watching
Oh
Rashid says I love this video lessons
they really pull me up and xenon says me
too bro
that's awesome I'm glad you that does
that for you I really appreciate you
saying that
okay
okay so spar spar willsez why is there
more than one CSS file I love that
question this this project I've this
website was built before I started
working here two years ago and it's been
worked on by a lot of different people
so a lot of different people at the
company that initially made it and then
different people here at the University
and it seems like everybody just kind of
added their file there was no attempt
made to minify or concatenate anything
so I have made some attempts to cut
things down and but there's still a lot
so we're gonna systematically try to get
rid of as much as we possibly can all
right there's some jQuery plugins that
were in here and you know that their CSS
stuff is just sitting in those files and
their JavaScript so that's why it's kind
of a mess normally I would never I would
never have set this up like this you
know if I was doing it from scratch but
there's quite a lot hopefully we don't
need that much and we can get rid of
most of it
okay actually jonbi maybe I
misunderstood the question because John
B's answer is a little bit different and
that's probably because I didn't
remember at what point we were at when
that question was asked so if you were
referring to all of these which I didn't
realize that was still on the screen
which you probably were referring to
then ignore what I just said before
while true that probably wasn't what you
were talking about these are all like
part they call them parcels I don't know
what they call them for sass but
basically these are partials so they
have this underscore underneath here so
these are all meant to be brought in to
a different file so if you see this
materialize scss we import all these
partials right all the smaller files so
you actually do end up with one sass
file that gets compiled or transpiled or
whatever we want to call it what do we
call it with sat from sass to the CSS I
don't know is it compiled transpiled
processed I'm not sure but anyway it
gets changed into this materialized dot
CSS so basically you know pretty much
like John B was saying these are all
it's just a way of organizing all the
different features so that you can
easily go in as a developer and change
what you need leave out some of what you
don't need you know I could go in here
so I click the wrong thing I could go in
here into this main file and just
comment out you know let's say I didn't
I didn't need the nav bar I just comment
out the nav bar and now when everything
gets changed into regular CSS all the
nav bar stuff is gone now I have found
that materialized is built in a way that
some of you can't just do that some of
these depend on each other so you you
will get errors at times so you have to
be careful about that it's not it's not
so straightforward but you could build
it in such a way that it would be more
straight for
like that but I've been able to do what
I need to do and get rid of a lot you
bet I'm not using before pretty easily
like this alright
okay so Shay yes hey Jesse how did the
weekend project go you were working on
something for your udemy class weren't
you yeah well my Udacity class but yeah
so I was hoping that it would be
finished and I could actually show you a
demo although it was I don't really have
time to do that today anyway so maybe
tomorrow I can get a finish but I it's
almost finished so yeah so thanks for
asking I worked on it like all day so it
worked on a Friday after I got home from
work for a while and like all day
Saturday and then I stayed up late
Saturday night so I did a lot of work on
it I got so much done it's really I
cleaned things up quite a bit it's with
Redux in my reducers were just like a
mess and now I've cleaned it up a lot
and it's working a lot better now so
basically it's just it's like a blog
site with comments and you can you can
vote so you can upvote or downvote the
blogs and the comments you can add
comments delete or edit comments and the
same thing with posts so I have all that
functionality ready I think the only
thing the last thing I did was I needed
to be able to sort the posts by date or
by vote so I got that working I just
need to apply it to comments as well and
I'm pretty sure that's the last thing
after that I just need to just fix the
UI a bit it's really basic the UI is all
I'll show it to you because I'm kind of
like just really messing around and
making a silly kind of UI for fun so
I'll let you see it when I when I'm
finished
so at that point I'll turn it in and
then they'll do a code review so
somebody from Udacity you'll do a code
review and then if anything needs change
they'll give it back to me and it's cool
even if I've met all the requirements
I'll still get suggestions for how to
make it even better which is cool so I'm
looking forward to that and I've started
the third section which is react native
so I've already started into those
lessons even though I'm not done with
the other project because sometimes I I
can just you know read the lessons and
watch the videos but I'm not really in a
spot where I can actually code something
so I could even do the lessons on my
phone when I'm just waiting you know in
line somewhere so so I've started to get
get to that I'm really excited about
about that so far it just looks really
cool see all Brett asks do you have any
redux code up on github I do so my the
project that I'm working on that I was
just telling you about is up on github
let me show you I don't remember what
the name of it is so that's why I'm
gonna show you let's see
here we go I think it's this one yeah
okay so it's my Udacity react and II
readable yeah this must be it
yep yeah so the sorting was the last
thing I did so this is it you can check
it out it in order to run it you have to
run there's a server that runs as well
so you'd have to get that from Udacity
so I didn't I really need to put that in
the readme but basically you run the
server and you make the API calls to
that to the other server so you wouldn't
be able to get any in for like if you
try to run this you wouldn't get any of
the information from the API calls but
you could at least see what's going on
there and I'm sure I'm making so many
mistakes because it's the first time
I've ever tried to use Redux so so just
if you want to check it out like to get
some ideas or to be exposed to Redux
just disclaimer I'm not sure that I'm
even doing it right I haven't even
turned in my project yet so that I'm
almost positive that that's not the best
way to set up a react or a Redux project
I'm you know I'm sure that there are
much better things I could be doing
because it's my first time like the odds
of me getting it perfect from only don't
hit once
all right so small so check it out if
you want to but I don't want to mislead
anybody into thinking that that's a good
example
see
Philip said when I was trying to ask
what you call changing sass the CSS he
says trans processfile yeah I don't know
there's got to be a name for it I just
not sure what it is okay let me double
check and make sure I got everything
okay
all right cool I think I did get through
everything let's see I kept thinking
that I was missing something like I I
missed somebody's question I was gonna
go back to it
I'll just take maybe like ten seconds
just to double-check cuz I don't want to
miss something
okay now I know what I saw okay so there
was a comment earlier about the lessons
like these video lessons it says that
they really pull me up
and that reminded me I just want to talk
about this just for just for a minute
because I need to yeah okay so I can
spare a minute for this although if you
know me it's definitely going to be more
than Meno probably more like five but I
just wanted to say I do get from time to
time like people will talk about in the
live chat like motivation the idea of
like how do you stay motivated and you
know some people would you know just
stay motivated to keep going projects
some people get down because they're
looking for work and they just can't
find it so I just wanted to talk about
that just really briefly because I know
you are going through some stuff like
that so I think I mentioned this here
and there before but like I I struggle
with motivation a lot I do my best to
try to sound as upbeat as I can during
the videos I said I don't want to be you
know just really boring and down I'd
rather be positive and upbeat for
everyone but like I struggle especially
in the morning you know starting to get
going and and one of the things that
there's a lot of things that help me so
like we've talked about this before I
exercise is a big thing that helps
caffeine helps me write vitamins and
things like that so staying healthy in
general helps out but sometimes you know
even more so basically like I recently
have been getting like super just super
depressed and not motivated and I've
been I've been struggling with
depression and you know taking
medication for it for years and recently
like it just got really worse and I got
put on another medication in addition to
the one I've been taking and I'd crazy
side effects so I got off of that one
and then had to weigh couple weeks to
see someone out
and get on a different medication and
now I'm taking something different but
it takes a while to kick in so it'll be
like I don't like a month to six weeks
before I can really tell and if it works
great if not I'll have to switch to
different ones so I'm just saying like
if anybody's struggling out there
struggling with that kind of thing like
I know a difficult that is so you know
my I'm open to if anybody needs to talk
on Twitter or if you want to bring it up
in the live chat or something so you
know I know a lot of other people
struggle with things like that and
sometimes it is just you know you get a
little bit of exercise and that helps
but other times it's more than that and
I don't know for me like a lot of people
just don't talk about it from you know
where I'm at I don't know how it is in
the rest of the world but it's kind of
something that's just like you keep
hidden and I don't think that really
helps it doesn't help people very much
to keep it you know to try to keep it
hidden I think it's better better to
talk about it so I mean this stream
isn't a mental health stream right it's
a coding stream so I'm still going to
keep it like 90 percent coding but you
know for if we're chatting at the end
doing question answers like you know
definitely open to any insight you all
have you're going through something like
that I'm open to open to talking about
that or talking privately about it but
I'm gonna do my best to keep putting on
these videos I almost didn't stream
today because I was just feeling so down
it came down to the wire if you know I I
didn't announce the stream until about a
half hour before I was going to cuz I
just like I just couldn't couldn't do it
I just couldn't get get motivated but
luckily I did I always feel better after
I stream and you know talk with you all
so anyway that's my
that's my heart to heart for this with
today's stream but actually I do want to
check to see if anybody responded to any
of that before I end the stream I guess
that did that took less than five
minutes so I was that's not bad I know I
tend to go on and on at times let me
double check really quickly see what's
here at the end of the live chat and
then we'll we'll wrap things up huh
Kevin says I don't actually like coffee
should I really my life as a developer I
don't know maybe you know everybody says
that developers you like they they drink
coffee in produced code right that's I
actually don't drink coffee that much
either I I mean you've seen me I
switched to energy drink I drink G fuel
and I feel much better I still like the
taste of coffee but I feel much better
if I drink the G fuel instead of instead
of coffee probably because there's a lot
of B vitamins and stuff in there that
coffee doesn't have
okay Brett says Jessie I built my resume
site from your videos and your fus
marcom /ci react project you're super
helpful oh that's awesome
that's really cool if you if you get a
chance send me a message on Twitter or
some something some social media and
send me I'd love to see see your resume
and see how you built it that would be
cool I mean obviously you base it on
mine but I'd be really interested to see
like where you change things and and how
you did things so if you don't mind and
you get a chance
send me the link please okay I just saw
you I didn't notice the second one so I
see that now so I will check that out so
if you wonder if I was laughing he
actually did put the link in right after
that and I'm I did just didn't even
notice it
okay I'm just typing it in so don't make
sure I got it right cool I see it
awesome I'm gonna check this up well I
got to go to a meeting in a couple
minutes but I'll check it out maybe when
I get back from the meeting maybe I'll
bring my laptop to the meeting and check
it out during let's see alright so
thanks thank you everybody for for
watching contributing in the live chat
really appreciate that as always and
I'll be back tomorrow and we'll work
some more on this and maybe we'll do on
that I might do the footer tomorrow I
think I want to skip I'm gonna skip down
and clean up the footer since it's
already there and we could already see
it I want it to look nice so maybe we'll
skip to there and then we'll start
working on the main content all right
[Music]
okay
Wow this video is less than an hour I
haven't done that in a while
shortness may be here for a long time so
I'm going to end it so it stays less
than an hour and yeah so that's all for
me have a great day